I want to talk about the games were most
excited about I've got these dates for
the ones that are confirmed I've got
released windows for the ones that
aren't uh really soon outlast too yeah
April 25th I'm super excited for this at
PAX East in 2016 I play this again
Marrakech and i played this being horror
game fans on you know Kelly you really
like horrigan [ __ ] general like two
hours of Ella that demo was awesome
right yeah well I played I played
extended unfortunately gameplay didn't
record only audio recorded that'll
happen but it really gave me like Blair
Witch vibes almost I mean aside from
holding a camera pretty much the whole
time uh it's kind of this back was they
have this like weird religious aspect
and it's creepy it's really creepy and I
think that the the setting works without
less sort of like chase stuff pretty
well notice I'm excited yeah the looking
over your shoulder or mechanic it seems
minor but it makes it terrifying when
someone's chasing you I really like the
first game I'm excited to see how this
is kind of blending different like there
was a poltergeist exes Chainsaw Massacre
thing kind of like resident evil 7 took
after uh I don't know I'm looking for
this game a lot and right on horizon
April 25th two days after that warhammer
40,000 dawn of war 3 we did a segment
last week on what's the state of the RTS
genre this game looks good I played a
little bit of this down la I think was
during III judges week last year spend
development for a decent amount of time
but I've been craving I played a
homeworld deserts of Carrick the other
week finally after not really getting
into it last year and you know starcraft
remastered gun announced in we were
talking about whether there's going to
be a resurgence of RTS or whether there
even was a decline but this game looks
fantastic i'm not a big war hammer fan
Dave Jewett over in the UK office loves
warhammer stuff but this game looks
great they have these Titan units which
kind of hero units but they're massive
the scale of this game looks really
appealing to me Ashley the singularity
last year that's accounting kind of a
touting facet was that it had like
massive scale you could zoom out to a
battalion level zoom into a unit this
seems like it has that and I'm really
looking forward to that I don't know
RTS fans here Kelly just reviewed halo
wars 2 but yeah yeah I love RTS games I
mean I'm not a big warhammer person yeah
but I wasn't maybe paint the little
things well figures yeah we're never
40,000 specifically I'm not and then
either neither with warhammer but I like
the total war war hammer last year um so
I'm hoping that they can use these
properties to you know Donna war three
to make it really fun too um right after
that may fifth this game I am pretty
amped for prey yeah so excited for bread
yeah like and another good immersive sim
after dishonor to last year which is
fantastic and definitely not the same
kind of game is Zelda or anything but
some of that emerging game PO that we
like talking about I feel like some of
those moments especially because prey is
open world it's just one big mission on
the space station rather than discrete
levels like in dishonor to or dishonor 1
i'm just i'm mentioning that because
arkane studios is working on prey they
made dishonored um I can't waive its
game everything I've seen about it we
did a live stream with Raph colantonio
and Ricardo bear from the team we have a
lot more stuff about prey coming out
soonish and Arkane Studios specifically
but the fact that you know the immersive
sim is making a comeback it seems to in
recent years after you know they were
all cult classics in the 90s with System
Shock the original thief deus ex the
original one Ultima Underworld being the
first one Ultima Underworld being the
first 3d like Oh RPG um do yeah you stab
yourself in the eye to get upgrades but
I can't wait for this game Rob you
played a little bit of it yeah I'm I'm
uh I'm looking forward to see I feel
like this game has a little bit of that
sandbox element of like you know
combining powers and like kind of you
know even that with that glue gun like
making your own routes but the mimic
right you think eventually you get the
power to to turn into objects how do you
and then you can use like a kind of
kinetic blast and just I'm expecting to
see a lot of cool gifts and stuff like
that you know almost in the same
respective like what Zelda did at least
that's what I'm hoping for it looks
really cool not respect
one thing I I'm like a little hesitant
about is the types of aliens I thought
what they called in this game your call
something anyways uh they all look very
similar I wonder how how that can affect
you after your 40 hours 50 hours like it
do you get bored of seeing like the same
black goo type of alien I don't know
that I'm just hoping there's a lot of
diversity with these things is all I'm
saying I don't know yeah i'm looking
forward that game seeing what they can
do with that may 16th injustice to
another kind of gods among your you like
fighting games but are you fan of a just
fighting games I don't love the nether
realm style of fighting um and I i liked
mortal kombat the last mo combat but i
did not get into injustice mostly
because i'm just not into this universe
but i know people who are do kind of
love this stuff and even the fighting
game community definitely embraced
injustice as well so i mean i think this
game will have some excitement around it
I'm not personally jazzed about it but
it you know people will be I don't know
it sounds pretty underwhelming the most
generic I don't know I know is I just
don't I mean I think this this has its
audience it's not going to really extend
extend beyond that right yeah and then
I'm not that audience ya know what the
audience thinks actually yeah I mean cuz
the first injustice released before
Mortal Kombat X yeah and then I'm eager
there was one before that too which was
like a weird hybrid of mortal kombat and
DC characters yeah but it was rated teen
so like when Joker fired a weapon it was
that I mean it made sense for the Joker
but there wasn't much gore but nether
realm did it though right blue so so
then yeah when I injustice came along I
mean it's not going to be as gory as
mortal kombat but from what I've seen
the characters look fun here Joe EE and
Eric Tay I don't know how excited they
are about it but I mean they were
playing it they're playing that alpha
the beta there's another fighting game
I'm more excited for mike is it on your
list why the hell isn't it on your list
tekken 7 on jun 2nd god damn it yeah oh
oh yeah wait hold on oh there it is
let's talk about
can 7 on jun 7th yeah uh kasahiro Harada
is a guy who makes great fighting games
he's very passionate about what he does
and tekken 7 has been stewing for a
while it came out in arcades months ago
maybe even a year now and they've been
perfecting it for 4 consoles and tekken
kind of had like a weird period of a
couple years but is since you know
taking it they've seemed to be taking
their time to do something that feels to
me it looks a little bit more like
classic um so yeah I'm really stoked for
this because I'm a little worn out on
street fighter now I don't love the
rosters I don't love what they did with
the whole package of 5 but they seem to
be adding so many things to make this
game interesting be it characters be it
modes be a wacky costumes and levels
like I'll take the the grand ideas the
deep ones and the superficial ones and
I'm just really excited to play a
fighting units that's gonna feel
different I don't know I don't know
anything about Tekken yeah I played one
like to back in the day I think and I've
from what I understand it's a decent
Tekken 2 up well yeah I mean three is
kind of like where the series like
became really popular in the eyes of
like like the whole fighting game
community for a while it was like one
into like yeah PlayStation has a decent
fighting game but you know like with
soul calibur Tekken 3 was the one that
really took the series you know to its
to its highest high and there's been a
lot of Tekken games since then obviously
if I was really good but six condon do
much for a lot of people tag tournament
2 didn't do much for a lot of people so
I don't know I like I don't think that
this game is going to be huge but but
but I can't wait to play it you know and
I hope there's gonna be other people in
the office that want to play it as well
I'll play I'm not alone cool um and then
in August which kind of just gotten out
so it's crazy it's August twenty second
release data middle earth shadow of war
another game I'm really excited for
personal and I Rob and Callie you're
saying both pretty pumped for it yeah i
would say anything like that oh you're
just not in a pretty tipsy oh yeah I
said Rob but then you were like head
lighting so they go she's seen excited
not doing that I'm just listening to you
active listener Rob woody excited for
his game it looks like the perfect
sequel like with like new mechanics
stuff like AG Adam right like
structurally yeah exactly but like yeah
in its essence just a sequel of like you
know where it left off from the previous
game seems to like really coincide with
like yeah new mechanics and you know you
the first game you amount to building a
whole army and it's like here you get to
kind of show it and that seems pretty
exciting almost makes me want to play
the first game again because of just
that idea but I think if there's one
thing the first game and we'll have to
see but the first game kind of got a
little repetitive to me even with that
nemesis system I don't how much you play
but eventually you kind of started
seeing like similar guys reappear on the
map after you would kill them as far as
like warchiefs but this again looks to
the kind of widen the difference is the
differences in like you know war chiefs
and like personalities again you can
like what like you have like a what was
the one I think they talked about where
you take over these were they called
strongholds right and you then have to
appoint one of your guys to do so and
previously one of the guys saved your
life you can appoint him or not and if
you don't he could quit and throw down
his weapons and then come back you know
20 hours later to be on the opposing
side and I want to kick your ass so I
know there's there seems to be a lot
going on with that a nemesis system now
middle-earth dating sim oh now I'm
excited yes I'm in all that head yeah
that is the oldest date an orc that
first date didn't go well um yeah I like
I like what they're doing like you were
saying Rob I love what they're doing
with this overarching strategy of you
know going from a Caelius to Mina's
Morgul to cure a thong going kind of
taking all these different fortresses in
the you know the mordoor universe and
you know building up an army rather than
this smaller battalion and having this
core of lieutenants that you are kind of
learning different traits and saying oh
the master of this fortress uses fire
and whatnot so I'm going to bring this
guy was on a warg so he's immune to it
so maybe he'll save my life I have a spy
that's been there for like three months
now maybe he'll help me out as a show on
his trailer we did a segment we kind of
actually commentated on this alpha
gameplay so you can go watch the
if you search on youtube search the
lobby shadow of war announcement we
walked through that I would love to talk
about it more but we already did that
right after that September eight that we
just found out destiny to a segment last
week and what we want from that Callie
you seem pretty excited about that i am
i'm excited for more good space shooting
with hopefully a world that keeps me
coming back for more than just good loot
i'm really looking forward to that I
just I really love the the shooting
mechanics in destiny and and I think
that although we haven't seen that much
I think that the the tone of the teasers
we have seen has been promising um just
like oh they're already setting up that
like something really bad has happened
and there's a lot of attitude on Cade
six-part so how do you feel about that I
was added I mean like I thought it was
like a lot but uh I think for a trailer
it was like that's probably how they're
gonna lean into it but I think the fact
that there in like a blown-out area and
there's clearly been an event is gives
me hope that makes sense wait yeah
hopeful hoping they make better use of
their universe in terms of a
storytelling or just the overall kind of
engrossing me in it because I didn't
feel that what the first game taken Cain
kind of remedy that in a few ways but
hopefully they push that further here I
mean he was like the comic relief right
yeah and you don't huh you don't
necessarily take a comic relief and put
them front center right as a main
character like you would hope they don't
use them to me when Nathan Fillion
voicing me do I mean he's he's
incredibly awesome in these trailers as
far as yet his voice over everything but
who knows to move on to games that don't
have set release dates but this one
slated for September red dead redemption
to I think that's the other one people
are really excited for that yeah I did
have a question from Twitter about
whether we really think it's gonna
release in September that was from
Andrew Klein 28 I think we did this
talked about this like right after the
announcement right like a couple months
ago barroom we did okay we did a stream
me Rob and Jake
I don't we have footage that it was very
early in the morning us through a crown
on the small couch in our studio we kind
of commentated on the trailer being red
dead redemption fans but P you don't
think it's gonna come out in September
uh no I just have a hunch that's not
gonna happen man they can they can push
this out whenever they want man yeah
they could poop this out they can really
see a game like destiny coming Billy
well we don't want to launch next to
that yeah push it why not I'm not saying
that that will be the reason I just
don't have a lot of hope outside of GTA
5 on pc is Rockstar ever been known to
delay something far oh they're usually
but I mean how long they've been working
on this since I mean not necessarily pc
but they delayed uh the online portion
for a while and then they delayed the
heists of the online many times and that
was a huge uproar like I think they did
that like like four times or something
like that happening yeah cuz I mean GTA
online was more of a platform right then
a singular game so you're kind of update
that almost like a destiny style but I'm
eager to see what they do with
multiplayer for red dead redemption too
I mean I'm obviously curious to see what
they do the characters and what's with
the story with the open world but I'm
looking forward to seeing how they kind
of influent that maybe like gangs kind
of writing across the Prairie this is
not releasing on pc though right is that
later then they show a title in the end
I think pc is not like a subsequent
release yeah like I'm saving I'm I'm shy
so that's slated for September right now
and then also some time in 2017 they
haven't really once they delayed it from
last year in December Ubisoft has not
told given a date for South Park the
fractured butthole um yeah i'm looking
for to that i actually finally played
the first one like a year ago it was
really funny it was really funny I I
love south park never really excited
then this isn't instead of going off the
you know the RPG tropes the first game
did fantasy stuff this is going for like
Marvel and superheroes and DC kind of
stuff plenty material there I yeah and I
love playing this game because it felt
like a season of south park told I'm
sorry the first game it felt like a
season of south park but I mean you know
I wasn't I wasn't in it for
fantastic gameplay although the
turn-based combat was pretty fun I liked
it for what it was obviously Trey Parker
Matt Stone worked heavily on it yeah
yeah and same with this i believe and
yeah and you can tell because those guys
play games I mean I we've heard
interviews with a play call of duty and
stuff like that like yeah what I would
say is like yeah you know they're very
great at satire right and that was very
apparent in this last game was that they
weren't just making fun of the fantasy
genre but they're making fun of games
and that's in themselves right like
quick time and I think even going to
canada right like how they like and i
can spoil it but yeah now for so long
but yeah you know how they like they had
really nice jokes and spins like within
the mechanics themselves just fun Earl
Devin courts just asking if there's any
really say for battlefront two yet we
just spoke about that last segment but
no there should be there might be
release date next week i'm assuming
there will be during Star Wars
Celebration when they make that
announcement last game i want to touch
on is a super mario odyssey for the
switch um will be this holiday season i
think they originally said with do they
say they're thinking december i think
they're thinking october okay i don't
know why i have that in my head but I
don't repeal bring this up that's that's
what I think about after looking it up
it just still 2017 right now but uh who
knows I don't I think I'm excited for
this but I honestly don't know I i am
not yet i am when they start showing the
other the weirder stuff than just this
nintendo fide New York it looks more fun
but I mean look these these games are
not necessarily about their worlds there
about their mechanics and the way that
the levels are designed around that and
like the fact that Mario can make his
own platform at any time now with his
hat and jump off of that like simple
change but that's gonna have a big
impact on how he feels as a moving and
jumping platforming character and you
have to imagine like I mean what was the
last ski it was super mario 3d world
right the game was a pretty safe play
like I I wonder how many interesting
ideas they've been holding off for for
like the next big Mario and this is the
one that is supposed to be like yeah
we're not really aiming for mainstream
we're aiming for like the people who
loved mario 64 right that I hate to use
the phrase but like that core gamer
audience
so I I hope they try to do some really
interesting things but this one the real
people next to Mario freaks me out like
more that should i just it really I'm
like why do they why are they normal
looking I don't like it and you look at
it and like what if you saw that Mario
walking around I'm town it's like that
time since I saw her he's one where he
goes into real life and he's walking
around he's all 3d yeah like it will see
freaks me out yeah I'm gonna play this I
I mean they just reinvented Zelda kind
of in a way and I'm yeah so I have faith
God yeah yeah another just need Metroid
but let's really talk about celiac
Chronicles X the game we've all been
waiting for yes there's no big cockles
to I should say yeah if someone mention
that chat earlier forgive me for
remembering your name thank you so few
people did and they said they said it oh
I think it was a Eric green maybe I
don't know um they said it might be like
Game of the Year contender but I
wouldn't go that far Xenoblade
Chronicles X had a lot of issues but
what I'm excited for is the fact I'm
monolith soft obviously who worked on
breadth of the wild the they have to
have gleaned some really interesting
stuff from that project and I would not
be surprised to see that benefit
Xenoblade in some way x had a lot x was
really cool for a lot of ways like you
had this big game and then at one point
you just you had mex you had giant
robots that you could pile and that was
like 60 70 hours into the game like
introduced or more really crazy concepts
but you want to talk about Zelda's world
and the scale and like you know how high
it is and how interesting just a simple
environment can be that is monoliths
office work and they have that has
always been their strong suit so I'm
really excited to see how they take that
to the next step with this game cool uh
yeah as always if you're in the chat or
if you're gonna be watching this on
youtube let us know in the comments if
we miss anything that you want to talk
about that you're looking forward to in
2017 let us know what you think of our
picks let us know what you're most
excited for and uh thank you
[Music]